un arsenal juridique qui soit beaucoup
plus fort pour arriver à faire entendre
notre voix
c'est difficile de retenir une seule
avancée parce que je pense qu'il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui ont été
concrétisées depuis notre arrivée en
2019 la présence de tous les députés
européens de notre délégation ça nous
permet véritablement d'avancer dans cet
objectif d'une robe qui soit plus verte
qui soit plus juste qui soit plus
démocratique qui s'affirme et ça c'est
un package global en fait c'est pas
juste un seul texte c'est un changement
de dogme un changement de mentalité et
c'est ce qu'on a réussi à construire et
c'est ce qu'on veut continuer de
construire
[Musique]
je pense que les le Mouvement Démocrate
et les députés du monde européen du
Mouvement Démocrate ont apporté leur
singularité dans l'exercice de mandat
parce que ce qui nous caractérise c'est
d'être des Européens on a toujours porté
les valeurs humanistes les valeurs
européennes ce qui nous renforce c'est
notre présence aussi sur le territoire
c'est ce lien permanent entre nos
territoires nos terroirs le niveau
national le niveau européen c'est
vraiment une singularité très forte du
Mouvement Démocrate et du Parti
démocrate européen
le mandat de député européen il a
renforcé mes convictions européennes
parce qu'effectivement j'étais de par
mes engagements associatifs de par mon
engagement politique convaincu que
l'Union européenne est le bon échelon
pour répondre à certains enjeux le choc
du covid la réponse qu'on a apporté en
européen le soutien à l'Ukraine qu'on
peut fournir à l'heure actuelle en
européen démontre à quel point l'Union
européenne est une nécessité
merci Laura de nous protéger de nous
protéger nos entreprises nos emplois nos
agriculteurs nos savoir-faire nos
territoires
[Musique]